let's talk a little bit about cnn's new
streaming service cnn plus now i know
some of you will say david what are you
talking about cnn plus i haven't even i
haven't even heard of that uh that's
exactly the problem i don't i don't
blame you if you haven't heard of it
i've only heard of it because i've had
conversations about it with with my
agent about do we want to make a pitch
to cnn plus and i'm going to get back to
that in a second um if you did not know
cnn plus launched it's part of why it's
already downsizing and this makes me
think even more strongly
that the future of media is going to be
in
sort of uh narrow casting independent
media uh there is a great report there's
a couple of reports actually that are
interesting a cnbc reporting cnn plus
struggles to lure viewers in its early
days drawing fewer than 10 000 daily
users now for people who don't
understand
how disastrous these numbers are
understand that
they are now two weeks into their
existence cnn plus
and they are seeing fewer than 10 000
people a day using the the streaming
service into which cnn has poured
millions and millions and millions there
are i don't know for sure
but there are probably individual cnn
plus shows
whose budget is multiple times that of
the david pakman show just one of their
shows they're getting 10 000 total
viewers a day
we are on 150 radio and television
stations
on satellite television
we get a million youtube views per day
we get 50 000 podcast downloads
per day per day per episode i guess
better said
um
and they're getting 10 000 viewers on
this entire thing
each day
and as cnbc reports the paltry audience
casts doubt on the future of the
application
following the uh following the recent um
completed combination of discovery and
warner media into warner brothers
discovery
uh warner brothers discovery ceo david
saslov hasn't commented publicly on cnn
plus his long-term future he told cnbc
in february he'd need to see how it
performs before making any other
decisions
people spoke with cnbc on the condition
of anonymity cnn plus launched on march
29
it cost 5.99 a month
those are our prices
those are that's that's amazing those
are our exact prices we charge six bucks
a month for membership and 60 a year
annually it only became available on
roku it's still not on android tv so i
guess as it grows then it might
you know i don't know i guess maybe
maybe it'll do better um
and they're already doing some
downsizing there's also an axios report
big cuts coming for cnn plus after a
slow start investment and projections
for cnn plus are expected to be cut
dramatically in response to a low
adoption rate
uh hundreds of millions of dollars
hundreds of millions are expected to be
cut from the original investment total
of a billion
to date 300 million dollars has been
spent i i just to put this in context
if we got a cash infusion
um
of 5 million dollars
it's insane what we would be able to do
with our show
if you get 5 million dollars for a show
like ours that has an established loyal
audience and we have distribution
methods and all these things
we just pour the money into youtube ads
facebook ads and twitter ads make it so
on youtube our videos show up as
pre-roll ads whenever you go to cnn or
daily wire
we take proven content and we just dump
money into putting it in front of people
the return on investment would be crazy
it would be crazy and there that that's
if we got five million in cash infusion
300 million dollars has been spent
for 10 000 viewers a day okay so that's
enough
i'm not ragging on them but what i'm
pointing to here
is
we have a very drastically different
media landscape
and in times past
the legacy power of cnn
or the legacy power of fox news or or
whatever
would guarantee success when you go oh
well let's also do streaming let's go
from legacy media to streaming
now because of the increased ubiquity of
the internet
the increased ability of the consumer to
say i i don't need cnn packaging 10
shows for me i'll pick my 10 shows and
i'll watch david pakman and then i'll
watch you know anthony magna bosco
street epistemology and i'll listen to
stephen novella's podcast and then i'll
go to no mickey's show where you but you
can build it yourself and it's really no
less convenient with all of the tools
that are around
so people just don't seem to care about
that curation
that was so powerful in legacy media you
can curate yourself
um
what else did i want to say about this
oh i've had i've had conversations
recently with my agent about
uh we've had inquiries from other
streaming networks i'm not going to name
them because it just doesn't doesn't
seem appropriate where they've said
would you guys want to submit a proposal
and i would go back and forth with with
my agent and
you know we would realize they want an
original proposal so basically what it
would mean is i would do this show every
day but then they would want me doing
another show only for them and when we
looked at the money involved and we
looked at the five layers of management
and oversight and editors i don't want
five bosses telling me what to do to
double my work every single day so we've
we've passed on even making some of
these proposals
um and it seems that as unappealing as
it was to us as content creators
at least cnn plus is appearing to be
pretty unappealing uh to consumers as
well so i think that this bodes well i
have no problem with cnn plus i just
think this bodes well for independent
media that's really what i think it
means where people are deciding for
themselves i'll curate
i don't need 24 hours of cnn plus let me
know your thoughts let me know whether
you even pay attention to these types of
networks